hello I want to play a game would you
watch the suppose at final installment
of a blood drive French I fall paying
three extra dollars to take it for 3d
does her nostalgia trump your
practicality live or die make her choice
saw 3d but at that point I wonder what
it's called when it's shown in 2d it has
to be called something else
does anybody know seriously so saw 3ds
more of what you've been familiar with
from the past six saw movies been gored
death and really clever traps when I
first saw the first saw say that three
times fast I thought to myself this is
the Riddler as he should have been and
in that I've always enjoyed the traps so
we've kept up on the Saw franchise you
know that the one carrying the torch is
Hoffman a big knucklehead of a dude
who's apparently clever and rich enough
to create these really convoluted traps
now the first saw was pretty clever and
that it had actually a couple of twists
in it be it bad acting but a couple of
twists after that I think one or two
have had some sort of a twist or
something but in all reality it is all
about the traps baby and we all watch
these people in these movies trying to
solve these traps but in reality we're
all thinking the same thing come on fail
fail and you know they're going to I
mean even on a filmmaking aspect they're
not gonna build this big elaborate trap
for you and have someone actually solve
it and be like oh sweet it all worked
out no one died and there is a lot of
failure and gore and saw 3d but the
thing that makes me laugh is at the
beginning of every saw there's a trap
scenario and someone's gonna fail you
know just kind of someone has to die to
kick it off for us at the beginning of
every movie and in this one it's because
of a love triangle between two dudes and
a chick
I mean seriously in saw six you took on
the CEO of a health insurance company
and now you're like those teenagers in
that love triangle they need to be
taught a lesson but like it would matter
to Hoffman I mean that kind of backslide
just just makes me laugh now you could
honestly [ __ ] about the character
changes that they do in the Saw movies
and the loopholes that they have to have
in these movies like I think it was soft
four or five or something like that John
Kramer's wife found out what he was
doing and she hated it and she was just
like is [ __ ] I'm leaving and now
she's down with it and she's like this
methodical villain or some [ __ ] weird a
little inconsistent I think but it is
saw and it's not made for story it is
made for one purpose and that is death
traps followed by death I mean pretty
much this movie feels like a best-of
compilation of horror traps it's like
there was a scriptwriter and a guy whose
sole purpose was to think of death traps
and bring him to the scriptwriter and
then at a point the studio just fired
the scriptwriter and had mr. deathtrap
guy just write the whole thing and it's
me in the movie was actually pretty good
I mean there were a couple of times they
used it really well I mean not as well
as jackass 3d but you know think that
statement might be the saddest statement
I've ever actually sat on my show so I
would say that saw 3d is the best sauce
since John Kramer died so from like four
through seven best one I mean it did its
job well the deathtraps some intense
[ __ ] in this movie I was gripping the
scene you know just standard saw
protocol right there so I would say
among the plot holes and the character
changes that I mean the Saw franchise
just loves to do and the fact that saw
is pretty much like 24 in that sense
that when you introduce a character just
know that that guy is just really not
going to last that long
you're gonna die so given all these for
what it is
saw 3d is actually a good time no
alcohol required for what it is if you
go by yourself you probably hate it but
if you go with a friend where you can
like you talk about what you liked about
it and then [ __ ] about what you hated
about it it's pretty fun but if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more than click right here to see
more